Prof: Let me start.
I'm going to read you something
and you have to guess what kind
of a scene I'm describing.
"A ghostly stillness
descended over the country,
this country today,
with every restaurant,
bar and teahouse in the country
closed.
Every store shuttered and
police patrolling the streets to
make sure no citizen dare to
step outside.
Avenues normally clogged with
traffic were so empty that
picnics could have been held on
them, except that nobody would
have been allowed to attend.
Plazas that are perpetual
nightmares of congestion and
exhaust fumes were abandoned to
wandering dogs and cats.
It was also a good day for the
fish because the thousands of
fishermen who line the
shorelines on Sunday were all at
home.
The waterway itself,
one of the world's busiest
waterways, was as flat and
silent as a woodland pond.
The government decreed a
six-month term--jail term for
any citizen who didn't spend the
day at home.
All in all, the country today
looked like a land on which a
neutron bomb had been dropped
devastating the population while
leaving the buildings
undamaged."
What do you think it is?
It's drastic.
Student:  The plague?
Prof: Nope,
good, reasonable guess,
but no.
Governments weren't as strong
then.
It's the census day in Turkey.
Some places take their census'
very seriously and require that
people really be in the place of
their residence so that they can
be counted and that they get a
very good set of numbers.
The waterway that they're
talking about between Europe and
Asia running through?
Student:  The Bosporus.
Prof: The Bosporus,
right.
Now compare this to another
country.
An educated and motivated guy
got one of the temporary jobs as
a census taker.
He was high class enough to get
an article published in The
Atlantic Monthly.
This is New York City.
I'll tell you because you'll
guess.
He was 6'4" and Caucasian.
They sent him to Chinatown.
People took one look at him and
slammed the door.
Others offered him money to go
away;
even most of those who tried to
cooperate did not have time to
fill out the long form.
He asked to be assigned to
another area.
He got Wall Street.
Same story, no one would
cooperate with him.
He couldn't even get into one
building, but this was a
motivated guy,
like a Yalie.
He climbed onto the roof of the
next building,
the building next door,
he jumped over the partition,
not across the street but over
the partition --
to get into the building that
he was supposed to take the
census of.
Right there on the roof was a
dilapidated shack.
Okay maybe someone's living in
the shack.
He knocks on the door,
someone inside flings open the
door.
Inside he could see several
apparently naked people lying on
hospital gurneys.
The man who opened the door was
wearing a white coat,
"Go away!"
He screamed,
"I'm giving my wife a
cancer treatment."
New York City.
A more experienced census taker
told him that he wasn't doing it
right.
What you have to do is what
they say, "curbstone
it".
What that means is you sit on
the sidewalk and guess how many
apartments are in the building.
You look up at the building,
you guess how many apartments
in the building,
and fill out that many forms
with guesses about how many
people live in each apartment.
That's the way censuses are
done in New York City,
a comparison to Turkey.
Now these are describing the
1990 Census.
I'll get to the 2000 Census in
a moment.
That census was the most
expensive ever,
it missed more than two million
children,
of course mostly minority
and imagine what this does for
school planning,
etcetera, etcetera,
it missed all together--
not counting just children--ten
million people and it double
counted,
or it counted in the wrong
place another six million
people.
Between censuses the census
bureau uses the count of the
last census to make its
projections.
They know the population is
increasing every year,
how much do we have now,
now, now?
By the time they came from the
1990 to the 2000 Census,
there were seven million more
people in America then the
Census Bureau thought there was.
The population had been
increasing something like one
and half times what they had
thought it was.
Does this slop matter?
The poor quality of the United
States census.
Well, nowadays these numbers
might seem small but more than
$185 billion dollars a year in
federal aid to states are
apportioned according to the
census results,
so every state really wants its
people counted.
On top of that,
what else is apportioned
depending on the census?
Congress, the House of
Representatives is apportioned,
so people want their state to
have as many representatives as
possible.
Given the importance of this,
why is it so bad?
Why is the U.S.***Census so bad?
The answer is primarily
politics.
It is well known,
the kind of problems that this
census taker had in New York is
very well known,
and it's well known that these
people that are considered
somewhat marginal:
minorities,
immigrants, poor people,
they are heavily undercounted.
This is well known.
The problem is that these
people don't vote Republican and
when this story that I'm telling
you takes place,
the Republicans controlled the
House of Representatives,
which controls the budget.
The census has been missing
this eight--
ten million for the 1990
Census, eight million for
before,
roughly eight to ten million
people,
and again, it's these minority
groups,
minorities, renters,
urban dwellers,
and so Democrats--and they
generally vote Democrat--
and the Democrats have been
pushing to get them counted,
to make an accurate account.
But a Republican redistricting
expert wrote a memorandum in
1997 predicting that adjustment
could cost the Republican Party
24 house seats,
which is a huge amount.
So, since then,
the Republicans have blocked
any modernization of the census.
For the year 2000 Census,
President Clinton appointed a
new director of the Census
Bureau, a woman named Martha
Riche who we've had here at
Yale.
She came out of a scientific
and research environment and was
really very competent,
scholarly, knew how to do it
right,
and she announced when she came
into office,
"All industrial
democracies will be holding a
census in the year 2000.
We want the United States to
win a gold medal for
accuracy."
She thought she was smart.
In fact of course she missed
the boat, because she thought
she was supposed to make an
accurate census,
and no, that wasn't what she
was hired for.
What she had proposed was a
statistical way of dealing with
this.
You know the groups that you've
missed,
you know where they live,
so after you've counted
everyone as well as you can in
the whole country,
you go back to the inner city
neighborhoods,
the various places where you
know that you're going to miss
people and you really blanket
that and do--
those areas very carefully,
a sample across the country.
Then you find out what your
errors are in that large sample
and then you can adjust the
whole population,
assuming you made the same
mistakes everywhere.
She was very open,
that's what she planned to do.
At the time,
though, Newt Gingrich,
I don't know if you know that
name with the New Deal for
America or something,
was the Speaker of the House,
controlled the budget,
and he said,
'yup, you have the authority to
do that,
you're the Director of the
budget ,
but, if you do that,
I will cut your budget to
zero.'
Basically she wasn't allowed to
do that and so she had to
resign.
She just would not do a census
that was less then what we're
capable of doing.
The census was done the old
fashioned way,
it cost $1.7 billion dollars
more than it would have with
sampling and was not anywhere
near as accurate.
Now these same considerations
apply almost everywhere.
In China, for instance,
you know about the one child
policy and the government is
strongly trying to push the
birthrate down.
We'll talk about this later in
much more detail.
A provincial official gets the
word this is--
we want your population growth
rate to be no more than whatever
percentage and then he sends it
down to the prefecture and down.
Do you think any of these
officials,
after the census,
are going send up information
that they have not been doing
their job,
that the birthrate is higher?
No, so there's problems with
that.
Who collects this data?
Well luckily several--many
organizations collect the data
but primarily the UN.
Who owns the UN?
Member countries,
and if you are,
say,
a conservative religious
country, and if the UN
demographer says that contrary
to government statistics,
that there actually is a high
rate of illegitimacy or abortion
in the country,
all of which comes out of the
statistics,
they're not going to allow that
to be published,
so the UN has to sort of cut
some corners so that the
countries from who it is
dependent on to get the data,
will continue to send them the
data.
In addition,
even when a country tries,
there are something like 50
million--
birth registrations not done
everywhere in the world and
there's something like 50
million babies,
worldwide, who were never
registered,
they don't exist on the
official registers,
so when you try to do what
demographers do,
you have a count of--a count of
a census in one year,
you have a count of a census in
a later year,
in between you have a list of
births and deaths,
supposedly both births are
registered and deaths are
registered,
and you see is this reasonable?
Is the difference accounted for
by births, deaths,
and migration if you have
reasonable amounts of migration.
If millions of the babies are
just not registered you can't
check things that way,
so there's a lot of problems.
Another thing is that in many,
many countries there's conflict
between different groups,
we've talked about Democratic,
Republican in the United
States.
In Nigeria, in Sudan,
there's a huge conflict between
the Muslim populations in the
north and the Christian or
Animist populations in the
south.
You may or may not recall the
Biafra War in Nigeria,
a huge war between
basically--over oil--but between
the Muslim north and the
Christian south;
millions of deaths and millions
of deaths now currently in Sudan
over something of a similar
issue.
When censuses in ethnically or
religiously split countries are
taken,
the key event is the ratio,
the key outcome that everybody
wants to know is the ratio
between how many Christians,
how many Muslims,
how many this,
how many that.
And so the censuses get totally
distorted by people trying to
raise their numbers and lower
everyone else's numbers.
Before the Biafra War there was
apparently a reasonably accurate
census in 1952 to 1953,
then the Biafra War intervened,
and the next several censuses
were very controversial.
So the accepted official
figures, in Nigeria,
were 88.5 million people,
but the World Bank said,
no, that's wrong,
102 million people.
The United Nations:
120 million people.
So, basically,
for a country as big and as
important as Nigeria for their
last census we have figures
ranging between 88.5 million and
120 million,
a 50% uncertainty for Nigeria,
so big.
The point of this initial part,
point one,
is that even the simplest
numbers like headcounts,
we're not doing anything fancy,
we're just trying to count how
many people there are,
1,2, 3,4, 5,
there are systematic errors and
very often those errors are
intentional.
Now all of these numbers--well
I say when I described these
numbers and I probably won't do
it enough.
When I put up a demographic
number it should almost always
be qualified by,
'and there are large and
unknown error bars,' but we
don't have error bars for it.
Various organizations collect
all this data and this is called
the Population Reference Bureau,
which is a source of statistics
and news,
everything about population and
it's a very big sheet here.
I'll show it to you blown up
and it has every region of the
world,
every country of the world,
and a large number of
demographic statistics for each
of these countries.
Let's look at one of these,
so here is one page of this
sheet--can you see that well
enough?
I don't need to put the lights
out.
What you see is the various
numbers that they count,
population, birthrate,
death rate, rate of increase,
migration rate,
in or out, plus for coming in,
out for going out,
what their projected population
is for 2025 or 2050,
and so forth down there,
a number that we'll try to get
to describe later called the
total fertility rate,
which is more or less the
number of children women are
expect--
will have as they go through
their lifetime.
Then on this side it's broken
down first into the world,
broken down by level of
development,
then by geographic region,
so there are a lot of really
very good data,
very clearly put on here,
and you can look first at the
world's population here,
so that's the first number in
the whole thing.
This is the middle of 2008 so
there were 6.7 billion people on
earth and still rising.
The expectation for mid-2025 is
8 billion and for 2050,9.3 or
9.4 billion.
Those are guesses about the
future and I'll tell you maybe a
little bit about how those are
done.
Look now at the birthrate here,
so this is births per 1,000
population and the birthrate of
the world is 21,
and I'm going to go crazy going
back and forth there.
How accurate is that?
Again we don't know,
large and uncertain error bars,
it's something like a third of
the children in the world that
don't have proper birth
certificates and you can't know
whether they've been counted at
all.
Another thing that you should
notice about the way it gets
organized--
is not only the world when it
breaks it down into development
categories there's less
developed countries,
that includes China and less
developed countries excluding
China.
It's important to get those two
things different because China
is considered very exceptional,
1) because of its one child
policy and they think that the
birthrate is abnormally
depressed,
and 2) it's tremendous rate of
economic development.
If you want a real
characterization of the less
developed countries,
even though China's average
income is very low,
it's changing very rapidly,
then you do it without China
and you get different numbers
there.
Look next at the birthrate
for--the birthrate for the whole
world is 21 per 1,000 per year,
and the birthrate for the less
developed countries is 23,
not a big difference.
Why is that?
How come it's so close?
Whereas, for the developed
countries it's 12,
why is the birthrate for the
world so close to the less
developed?
Student:  Because the
majority of the population
resides in those places.
Prof: Right,
the overwhelming majority of
the population is in the less
developed countries,
so whatever we understand about
that,
that is what we have to--that
is characteristic of the world.
This difference in birthrate
between say 12 in the more
developed countries and say 23,
26, even 36 for the least
developed countries,
that is a huge difference.
It's a factor of three between
the most developed and the least
developed,
and a factor of something like
2.5--
over 2 in between,
which means that now most of
the world is--
in the underdeveloped countries
most of the population and that
will continue and will get more
extreme.
Here is an example of that,
this is--we are now about here
and the more developed regions
like the U.S.
are still growing very slightly
but basically going to be flat
as far as one can project out
here,
but the less developed
countries are undergoing this
population explosion.
If the ratio between the less
developed countries and the
developed regions is this now,
that will only increase after
2050 out here.
This--that the world is
demographically characterized by
the poor countries is a fact
now,
and a much better fact,
as time goes on,
a more complete fact.
That's--the first point is
about inaccuracies of
statistics,
the second one here is that
it's not the developed countries
when you think of what's
happening in world population
don't think of the developed
countries,
what's happening is what's
happening the underdeveloped
countries or the developing
countries.
Now let's shift and look at the
death rate.
We looked a little at the
birthrate, and you notice
something very interesting;
here's the birthrate we've just
been saying for the world 21 per
1,000 per year.
Look at the death rate,
eight, that means there's more
than two and a half times in the
world now--
there's two and a half times as
many births as there are deaths,
an enormous difference and you
can compare,
in the less developed regions,
there's something like three
times as many births as there
are deaths,
9 deaths, 26 births,
so there's a huge--
right now there's a huge
imbalance between the births and
the deaths.
As you know population
stability, which many people
think would be a good thing for
the world,
depends on the deaths and the
births being equal,
which means that the world is
out of kilter,
the ratio between births and
deaths is now out of kilter by a
factor of something like 2.5 to
3;
2.5 for the world,
3 for the developing countries.
What that means is either the
death rate has to come up to
that level or the birthrate has
to come down or some
combination.
Part of this is,
well, we'll see--what's going
to happen with part of it a bit
later.
The major point of this is that
the world is very far from
population stabilization.
You've probably heard lots in
the news about declining
birthrates in Europe,
and Japan and so forth,
and our next lecture will be
about that,
will be just about that.
It's not characteristic of the
world.
The world is way out of
balance, and even in the United
States which is one of the few
developing countries that still
is having a population increase,
we have 14 births for every
eight deaths,
and that's 1 and 3/4 times the
number of births as deaths,
so the United States is way out
of whack,
and that's births versus deaths.
That doesn't include
immigration.
It includes the children of
immigrants that are born in this
country but doesn't include
immigration,
so our births plus immigration
is going to be at least double
our birthrate,
so our population is also not
anywhere near balanced.
Okay, now unlike the birthrate
which is very different in
different parts of the world,
the death rate is not
extraordinarily different.
Here--I see you squinting;
can you see it well enough?
The death rate in the developed
countries is 10 per 1,000 and in
the less developed countries,
again without China,
it's 9 per 1,000,
a very small difference.
The reason for that is,
is that mortality has fallen--
because of vaccination
programs, especially vaccination
programs,
oral rehydration for diarrhea
and a lot of very basic public
health matters,
not open heart surgery or
anything like that,
but the most basic public
health measures has dropped the
death rate in the world
tremendously,
again especially the infant
death rate.
Sub-Saharan Africa is somewhat
of an exception to that.
Anybody remember--maybe you
studied it, what I said was sort
of pre-modern death rate,
somebody said it,
I think they said it right;
about 40 per 1,000 and now it's
down to Œ
of that which is a modern rate
and it's not going to decrease
an enormous amount more.
Fertility--so the changes in
the death,
when you look about the future
of population,
further changes in the death
rate will have some effect but
not an enormous effect.
Its change in the fertility
rate, the whole future world
population depends essentially
on the fertility rate.
A little bit from a change in
the death rate,
somewhat from people aging,
but primarily fertility rate is
what you watch to find out
what's going to happen in the
future of world population,
unless of course we have atom
bombs or something like that and
everybody dies.
Now as an example of this
death--flatness of the death
rate -- this is from Egypt,
there's a lovely graph notice
the little baby in swaddling
clothes.
This is from the Egyptian
Statistical Abstract,
the Egyptians published this
themselves, and it's not the
most recent.
It goes up to about 1990 and
maybe now they've gotten more
computerized and don't dress the
things up like that,
but I just liked that and that
color is the original color in
the original statistical report.
Notice the number of births
increasing continuously with
some small dip here but
basically it goes from 1,000 to
up here would be 2,000.
In this period of time the
birthrate nearly doubles and
this is absolute number of
people,
not a percentage,
but look what happens in the
death rate,
very little change.
The death rate,
starting way back in 1952,
so way before a lot of very
modern kind of medical stuff,
so it's basic medical--basic
public health,
basic sanitation that's
responsible for this.
So the number of deaths is
staying more or less constant
and of course the natural
increase,
the increase in the population
is the difference between births
and deaths,
so you have it increasing every
year,
you get more and more
population increase.
This is the population
explosion and you've seen
numbers like that.
Now is the death rate staying
constant?
No, the death rate is not
staying--because the population
is increasing and yet you're
having the same number of
deaths,
so the percentage of the
population that's dying each
year is going down slowly,
not at a -- as a percentage --
it is a slow decrease,
so over this period time period
and continuing,
the death rate is decreasing
but not in a--
significant enough to make a
big difference in the total
population growth statistics.
The basic thing in the world is
that the fertility rate is what
can change a lot,
can make the difference between
a world whose population keeps
growing or stabilizes or starts
decreasing.
Now, anybody notice anything
funny so far?
One number that should
have--one pair of numbers that
should have--what?
Let's go back to that,
anything funny about these
numbers?
Student:  The less
developed countries have a
little less.
Prof: Yes,
so the less developed countries
have a lower death rate than the
more developed countries.
That's surprising that their
health systems or their health
is better than ours.
Let's just check that number
and let's look at for instance
compare the United States with
our neighbor,
Mexico.
We know Mexico is much poorer
and probably doesn't have as
good a healthcare system,
well here's our deaths per
1,000 in the United States is 8;
Mexico is 5,
it's a good bit less then we
have and further,
here is Central America there's
not a single country that's as
high as we are.
Every single one of the Central
American countries,
including some pretty poor
countries,
El Salvador has a lower death
rate then the United States and
Mexico is kind of in the middle
between the 4 and the 6.
Striking, you go further afield
here, here's the Caribbean and
these are more in the range of
the U.S.
level but they're--the U.S.
is not better than almost any
of them except for Haiti.
Haiti is the only place that
has a noticeably worse death
rate then us.
Student:  Do those death
rates include the infant
mortality rates?
Prof: What?
Student:  Do those death
rates include the infant
mortality rates?
Prof: Yes,
these are total death rates.
Once you're born,
if you die after you're born,
you're counted.
Don't include spontaneous or
induced abortions.
We got a problem here,
what do you think is the reason
for this?
Student:  Because the
United States has more older
people than other countries.
Prof: Exactly,
the United States has more
older people,
and it's a funny thing about
they're the ones who tend to
die.
Once you get rid of your infant
mortality issue,
people tend to die at the older
ages.
That's exactly correct,
and it's an extreme--in a
developed country it's an
extreme difference.
Here is what's left,
so this is the United States.
This is the deaths per 1,000,
the age of the people,
and here's what's left of the
infant mortality,
it's still more dangerous to be
an infant than later,
but there's virtually--you
can't even see the death rate
through the middle years,
but then boom it goes up as you
get on into the older ages.
Indeed, the death rate is
completely sensitive to your age
distribution,
a country that has more young
people will have a lower death
rate.
A country that has a high
birthrate will have more young
people,
will have a lower death rate,
so what you're seeing in that
anomaly there,
what looked like an anomaly,
is basically that Mexico has a
higher birthrate of people.
This funny thing,
you happen to be born young and
you die old, and so that is the
explanation for that.
Any time--almost any
demographic number that you want
to interpret,
marriage rates,
birthrates, death rates,
fertility rates,
almost everything of interest
is affected by the age
distribution.
In understanding demographic
statistics, the most important
thing is always the age
distribution.
You always have to pay
attention to that,
and later on I'll show you one
of the mechanisms for paying
attention--
for getting
statistics--adjusting statistics
for the age distribution.
How--first let's just look at
it.
So here is the easiest way of
looking at an age distribution.
What you have here,
this is for Germany and the
pink is the old--
this is 1989 when East and West
Germany were still split,
so this is the German
Democratic Republic,
East Germany,
the pink is East Germans and
the dark is the Federal
Republic,
West Germany,
and on the left is men and on
the right is female,
male and female,
and what this graph says is
that every year--
so this is age zero,
you're just born,
to age 100, that every year
they ask how many people are
there?
How many kids are there between
age zero and one?
Well there's so many males and
so many females,
this number in East Germany,
this number in West Germany.
You can go through every age
and just count from your census
the number of people at that age
and draw it out like this.
It's a wonderful huge amount of
information in a single graph;
you can see all kinds of things.
This is World War I,
the people born during World
War I,
they're almost all gone,
but here's the ones from World
War II and look at the big
difference.
Here's your females.
Here's your males.
What's the difference?
War deaths;
the men are in the Army and the
get shot up on the Russian
front, so you have many more
females then males.
It's partially that women live
older also but this case in
Germany is almost exclusive--
is overwhelmingly the deaths
from World War I,
here there's still some
females, there's no males,
and then the deaths from World
War II.
You can see the birth deficit,
these are people who would have
been born during World War I,
these were adults,
fighting age adults during
World War I.
These would have been born
while the men were away so they
didn't have any babies.
They had very few babies during
World War I and the same thing
you see for World War II,
and you see again the deficit
of--well we talked about that.
You can see that,
then you can see there's a post
war baby boom,
after the deficit in World War
II people make up for it and
more than make up for the
deficit,
so you have this huge bulge in
population,
both males and females,
but now balanced,
more or less equal numbers of
males and females,
and then you get the baby bust
and you get a little echo
effect,
so there's
variations--fluctuations in
population--
almost every country
has--Western country has these
kind of data plus the Asian
countries that were involved in
World War II.
You can see it's a wonderful
way of understanding a country.
Now this is India--the census
of India, that's a weird one.
What the heck is going on there?
That's weird,
so what it is,
is people don't know their
ages,
they're innumerate,
and so it gets counted every
five or ten years,
so here's a five year or a ten
year period.
They know their ages
approximately,
to approximately a certain
year, they don't know it
exactly.
It's not important,
in a pre-industrial country
their exact age is not all that
terribly important.
You get this--that's called age
heaping, that when you get a
large excess in five or ten year
increments.
My own father,
who was an immigrant,
did not know his age.
There was--he was born in
either 1904 or 1907 because he
even had a birth certificate but
it was in the Russian Cyrillic
characters and the four looks
like a seven,
so he and my mother argued
constantly over how old he
actually was.
Even countries that have had a
long--European have the same
thing.
Here is the Soviet Union from
their 1937 census and here again
you get this same age heaping
effect.
Not quite as extreme as India
but very clearly here,
and to a degree worse with
women then with men,
because women are less
educated, see the big bars here,
the small bars here,
and in principle it should be
getting less with younger people
it should be clearer,
and you certainly do get rid of
these extreme on certain of
these but it's not--
it's persisting into the 1930s
this 'I don't know how old I am
except within a five or ten year
bracket.'
Here's another weirdo,
what's that?
Just to show you that you can
immediately, once you get used
to this, immediately tell an
awful lot about a country from
an age pyramid.
Anybody from Arizona?
Nobody from--what?
Student:
>
Prof: It's Sun City,
Arizona which is a retirement
community and they don't allow
anybody--
I think most of these have an
age limit of 50,
you have to be at least 55,
so this is the retirement age,
and where my mother lives in
Century Village in West Palm
Beach looks like this --
Florida looks like that,
various retired--
California has retirement
villages they look like that.
These population pyramids are
wonderful with lots of
information packed into this and
from seeing these pyramids you
can tell a lot about the
socioeconomic character of the
countries because we know that
the poor countries have less
literacy,
etc., etc., and they have
higher birthrates and so we'll
look at what that looks like
right now.
Here are two of these
population pyramids and here
is--
you saw in those the splitting
of the world into more developed
regions,
and less developed regions.
What do you notice right away?
The total area under this,
so this is now five-year age
heaps rather than single year,
so between zero and four is
this amount,
or this amount,
so it's the area under this is
how many total people there are.
One you see there's a lot less
area here,
a lot less people,
the less developed regions are
the bulk of the world but also
the shape is very different.
Here in the developed regions
you have a more or less similar
number of people in all ages.
It's not exactly that way.
Of course at the old age people
are dying and that starts about
here in the 50s and then
accelerates and there's very few
left,
so it narrows here and also
it's narrowing down here because
the birthrate in the developed
countries is now below
replacement level and so the
pyramids are getting to be fewer
people in the younger ages then
there are older people.
Contrast that with less
developed parts of the world and
you see that there's more and
more younger people,
each age cohort has more and
more people.
You can look at an individual
country, and this is a clearer
example.
This is Nigeria as far as we
can tell from their census,
but they--you can tell an age
distribution and this is now
percent rather than total from
sub-samples,
you don't need to count
absolutely everybody to
understand what the age
distribution is.
Here is a 50-year change,
there's not one--it's not
changing very much.
This is what it was in 1975,
they know more or less what it
is now, and they're projecting
it out to 2005--;I'm sorry.
This is pretty current and it
looks about the same,
and vastly as you go in this
case, as you go to younger and
younger people,
vastly more children than older
folks.
So what's happening here--see
what the ages are here,
especially in Nigeria,
15 to 45, these are the ages in
which women are giving birth and
this number of women is giving
birth to more than two children,
they're more then replacing
themselves,
so each bar is bigger than the
last,
and some of this in-swing,
especially this is Sub-Saharan
Africa,
some of this reduction is
infant mortality and child
mortality.
Some of the differences,
especially between this bar and
this bar, that's in there,
but it's a small effect.
The major effect is that every
generation is bigger and they
produce more and more children
here.
Now--so when you look at
how--what's going to evolve in
the future--
so here is your women who are
40 to 45,
that's this bunch of women and
women on this side,
so that's the number of women.
They're producing part of these
children.
In another five years,
if you look at this five years
later, these women who were 40
to 45 are now 45 to 50,
no more fertility,
pretty much.
In Nigeria they're not using a
lot of IVF and everything.
So they have stopped
reproducing but that cohort of
that size is being replaced by
the ones of this size coming
into fertile ages,
so women that were 10 to 15 are
becoming 15 to 20 and starting
their childbearing,
when women that are 40 to 45
which have not so much
childbearing left,
are going out of existence and
stopping childbearing
absolutely.
The number of women,
the number of child bearers is
increasing drastically.
In this case,
it looks ballpark like there
are twice as many women coming
into reproductive age as are
leaving reproductive age,
each year, each five years
however you want to count it.
The number of childbearing
women is increasing
tremendously.
The result of that is--here's
another comparison,
whereas in the west,
in developed countries the
number of 40 to 45 year olds is
not enormously different then
the number to 15 to 19.
So the women that are leaving
reproductive ages are more or
less replaced by the women that
are coming into reproductive
ages.
Of course with population
decline,
eventually you get fewer women
coming into reproductive age in
developed countries then are
leaving it,
so that you have fewer child
bearers,
so this phenomenon can--if your
population is increasing the
problem gets more and more
severe,
if it's decreasing the problem
gets more and more severe.
There's a positive feedback on
this with your number of child
bearers either growing or
decreasing.
Here is in billions--the number
of women of childbearing age in
the world, and it just keeps
increasing, right?
What you may be aware of,
I haven't really talked about
this much yet,
because it's in my next
lecture, here is the birthrate
in the world,
children per women.
The birthrate has been coming
down.
Two opposite things are
happening in the world.
The number of childbearing
women is going up but the number
of children that each of them
have is going down.
They predict optimistically
that by 2050 it'll reach about
replacement of about two
children per women,
but it's not there,
we're not there yet,
we're almost double-- we're way
above that now.
The result of this number of
women rising,
their rate of childbearing
decreasing is that the number of
births,
you sort of multiply those two
out,
the number of births is
expected to continue increasing
for the predictable future.
That the absolute number of
births will increase as a result
of these two crossing factors.
Now the birthrate is coming
down and it eventually,
let's presume in the future,
gets to be two children.
What then happens?
You still have a pyramid like
this but now it starts
flattening out,
but it flattens out--I should
not do this by hand.
In fact I want to go to this
graph.
It shows this--this is what's
actually predicted to happen,
so this is again developing
countries and this is the kind
of pyramid that we've seen.
This one goes back to 1985 with
this broadly increasing thing.
It's basically a triangle,
you can think of it is as a
triangle.
If immediately,
God sticks his finger out of
heaven and says two children,
and even more surprising,
people obey him,
what happens?
This is the number of children,
people that there are there,
that the population pyramid
will grow up but with this as a
base,
so that it will become square
but there will be this many
people.
You go from a triangle to a
rectangle with the same base.
Can you see that?
The number of people is the
area inside that and you have
the same base,
you go from a triangle to
rectangle--
remember from high school
geometry what the area is?
It doubles.
Because, if you have a triangle
and you go square,
you just flip that--half the
triangle over and you've got
that many people again.
If a miracle happens and
fertility stops dead right now
and we go immediately to two
children per woman,
the population doubles before
it stabilizes.
What this shows you,
of course is that miracle is
not going to happen.
This is quite optimistic and is
already not the case,
that the base will also
increase.
Since the population is still
increasing,
the base will increase,
and yes it will get more
rectangular,
but even by 2025 it won't yet
be rectangular,
so that you will,
on this kind of projection,
more than double the population
from 1985 because the base is
growing as well as you're rising
up.
There's an expectation of quite
a lot of population increase
left.
This whole phenomenon where
because you--
once you start having an
increasing population you're
going to--
the population is going to keep
increasing because there's more
and more child bearers unless
something drastic happens to the
fertility rate,
it's called population momentum
because you're sort of moving in
a certain direction of
increasing population,
it just continues.
The same thing happens as
you'll see in the next lecture
with population decreasing,
and when population decreases
you have fewer and fewer child
bearers in each generation,
as say Japan now or Singapore,
and so unless the birth rate
increases tremendously you'll
have fewer and fewer children.
What this shows you is that,
if there's immediate
replacement,
this kind of miracle that
everything--
that everybody comes to just
two children immediately,
then the population would be
this, so this effect is all
momentum.
All of this increase,
from where we are now to up
here,
is just a momentum effect,
just the fact that there's more
and more children coming into
reproductive age and that takes
a very long time to work out.
Then the fact that there's in
fact -- they're not going
immediately to two children,
not immediate replacement.
This is the United Nations
guess as to what's going to
happen.
The actual population is
projected to go like this.
If everybody immediately goes
to two children you get this
population rise.
What is actually expected is
somewhat more,
so huge amount of what's
happening with population future
is already determined,
it's already momentum is in
there and even if birthrates
really come down very rapidly,
the world's population is going
to continue increasing.
That's sort of an important
thing to remember.
In the world the fertility is
decreasing, the population is
increasing and those are not
canceling out.
From 1985 the prediction was
that the world population would
somewhat double,
we've made some progress
between there,
but still we have 6.7 billion
now and the expectation is
something like 50% more people
on earth in 2050 and perhaps
continuing to increase beyond
that.
Huge amount of momentum
effects, here is--
let me go back--this is
Mauritius, an island in the
Indian Ocean and it's one of the
examples of a small
underdeveloped country that had
a very surprising fertility
decline.
This is probably the influenza
epidemic here,
but starting in around--right
after World War II in the late
1940s, it's death rate fell
down;
modern public health comes in
to Mauritius,
so the death rate falls
dramatically.
Then this fits the standard
characterization of the
demographic transition.
About 20 years later,
about one generation later,
people learn,
well we don't have to have so
many children because they're
not dying,
and the birthrate comes down
thereafter and population growth
is in here.
This is a country that did
well, that starting fairly early
for a developing country,
1951 say, their birthrate is
falling down.
They really sort of got it
under control and--but look at
this.
So this is the birth--the total
fertility rate which is a birth
rate here,
and it stays stable and then it
starts falling down quite
significantly,
but look at here's total
population size.
You don't even see a change;
all momentum.
Here the birthrate has started
dropping in 1965 and now we're
25 years later and you don't see
hardly any change in the
population growth rate.
That's what we talk about by
the momentum effect that because
at this time,
before they drop their
fertility, at this time there
were so many more children than
older people that the number of
women child bearers just kept
increasing and increasing,
and increasing,
so even though fertility drops
the number of children stays
high,
even gets higher,
and the population just keeps
increasing.
It's a very,
very strong effect and the
number of--and it's not
flattened out there yet,
25 years later.
This is a projection of how
long does it take before it
flattens out.
This is the first one,
the first box is the year--this
is our current size as of
whatever year this was.
By 2030--this is the United
States.
This is the number of people,
so this graph was made in--
it doesn't say the date but our
population will increase
somewhat by 2030 and this really
is ignoring the changes that
have happened with immigration
and so forth that we will--
we reach two child--if our
fertility comes down we reach
two child in 2030 and we
stabilize because we have not
had a rapidly expanding
population so we stabilize right
away.
Nigeria, which you saw,
current population,
it's supposed to but some
optimistic assumptions reach two
children per women in the year
2035,
but then it doesn't stabilize
until 115 years later at again a
much increased population.
In the case of Nigeria,
after it reaches two child per
woman,
after it reaches replacement
level,
it takes another 115 years
before population actually
stabilizes.
This is Bangladesh, 125 years.
This is Iran, 110 years;
Iran has had a big crash,
we'll talk about that and its
population.
Brazil 145 years,
it takes an enormous amount of
time for momentum to work itself
out after the fertility rate
comes down.
It's quite striking,
and that's the reason why we
expect so much more population
growth to happen.
Again, you can look at an
individual country,
and this is Algeria,
and look at what Algeria has
done between--in 20 years:
that's an enormous rate.
Here's its crude birthrate,
it's--crude means not corrected
for age or anything,
just take 1,000 people,
how many babies were there for
that 1,000 people.
In 1965 there were 50 and it
dropped to 38,
a very large drop and it's a
drop of 24%.
They cut their birthrate by a
quarter, that's 25% in 20 years,
that's more than 1% a year,
so there's a very,
very rapid change.
Because of momentum the
population growth rate was 2.4%
in 1965 even though the
birthrate is going down the
population growth rate is going
up,
all momentum,
and the percent of change that
the growth rate increased by
19%,
again all of this,
because at this age,
they had been having a
population explosion,
so many younger children than
older.
The population almost doubled
from 12 million to 22 million,
population went up 83% and the
annual population growth rate
increased from a quarter million
to 600,000;
0.6 million, it changed 217%.
Here's the dilemma for
developing countries,
that basically all the
developing countries understand
that they need--
that economically they'll be
destroyed if their population
growth rate increases and
virtually every developing
country has now an official
national policy of trying to get
its birthrate down.
We'll see later that that's
okay with the people,
they're generally in accord
with this, and they can do
wonder--they can do miracles.
These countries--you'll see
some of the drops next time,
I'll talk about--next time in
my lecture I'll talk about some
of the fabulous drops.
I mean this is not exceptional,
this is a very significant drop
but it's not exceptional around
the world,
and yet, even in the face of
that, their population goes up
into massive amounts,
83% up, 100% up,
more than somewhat.
As the government is pushing
modernization,
and as the government is
pushing reducing the birthrate,
and as grass roots
organizations push to try to get
the birthrate down,
the population keeps increasing.
Industrial development,
if it's not extremely rapid,
can't keep up with the
birthrate, so while these
countries are modernizing they
can see conditions deteriorate,
poverty can grow,
crowding can grow,
homelessness can grow,
again because population,
even though you get your
birthrate down,
your population keeps
increasing so extremely.
Some theory--believe that
there's kind of a window of
opportunity for the developing
countries that,
for instance,
you take Egypt which I'm sure
it's also had one of these drops
not unlike this.
They were kings of the world,
top of the world in the
Pharaoh's time,
you all know that kind of
history.
Then iron was invented,
but not in Egypt,
and Egypt was in the bronze age
during the Pharaoh's time.
Iron is invented maybe in
Turkey, I don't know exactly
where and the other people's of
the world picked up iron and
made iron swords.
The Egyptians,
for some reason,
never really caught onto iron,
maybe they don't have any iron
anywhere there,
and so from 1000 BC or
something until 1950 they were
always subject to somebody else.
They were always ruled by
someone else until Nasser got
rid of the British in 1950,
they were ruled by the British,
and then before that by the
Turks,
and by all kinds of peoples,
the Greeks before that--
in Alexander the Greats time
and so forth,
and the Romans,
they were ruled by someone
else.
Well here come--here's 1952 I
think, Nasser's revolution,
gets rids of the British,
sets up an independent
republic.
The people are very
enthusiastic,
they're very excited,
they now throw off the shackles
of imperialism,
and colonialism,
and they can now be their own
country.
But the birthrate is still very
high, the population growth rate
is very high,
they have to industrialize real
fast.
They can't and they don't
industrialize that fast,
they don't modernize their
economy.
Why?
A whole lot of reasons,
one of which is they waste huge
amounts of money on the conflict
with Israel,
that they have war after war,
and have to spend huge amounts
of money on the military that
would be better spent on their
economic development.
Time passes,
and the people have tried to
modernize,
that's been the ideology,
they've tried socialist
modernization,
they've tried capitalist
and what they see is more and
more crowding,
poverty is not going away.
Conditions are not getting very
much better.
I mean they do get a little bit
better, but not terribly much
better and so they give up on
modernization.
When they give up on
modernization they glorify the
past,
they say it was better in the
and they go to a romantic
attitude to what it was like
in--
and can try to reverse
modernization by resisting
further drops in birthrate,
for instance,
going back to religion.
When I was in Egypt some years
back,
went into some sort of a
restaurant and they seat you
sometime at long tables,
so people you don't know you
sit next to,
and if they happen to speak
English I could talk to them,
I don't speak Arabic,
and so the ones that I could
talk to were upper class--
educated people and therefore
upper class people that spoke
fairly good English.
And you meet this nice young
woman and she was at the
University of Cairo which is an
elite school,
and she was an engineering
student,
so perfectly intelligent,
perfectly modern in that way,
wearing a head scarf,
which her mother did not wear
which was not in the previous
generation.
That she doesn't believe in
modernization basically.
For her own self-benefit she'll
become an engineer because she
wants a decent job.
She doesn't want to herself go
back and dig in the desert dirt
there to try to get some food.
She wants to be a modern person
with a good job,
at least she wants a good job,
but she doesn't believe in
modernization.
The rest of her ideology,
aside from her personal
desires, is backward looking,
that things were better in the
past, modernization has not
worked.
This is--there's this window of
opportunity when countries first
try to get modernized and one of
the things that goes along with
modernization is a reduced
fertility rate.
If it doesn't work people will
reject that.
A lot of what's going on in the
world today with respect to the
developed and underdeveloped
countries,
and the Arab countries,
and the Western countries,
has to do with this rejection
of modernization because it did
not work for them.
With that, if the birthrate
stays high as it has,
not in the Muslim countries.
Many Muslim countries have had
fabulous progress,
but in a lot of the Arab
countries the birthrate has
stayed very high,
and there's these huge numbers
of unemployed young men,
the economy cannot absorb them,
they're hanging around,
they're idealistic as all young
men are,
and what ideals do they pick up
but going back to some imagined
past that was glorious.
The world may hinge on this
window of opportunity.
How many countries can take
advantage of it?
China clearly took advantage of
it, Japan took advantage of it.
A lot of the East Asian
countries took advantage of
their window of opportunity,
a lot of other countries did
not take advantage of their
window of opportunity.